hey everyone it's haley i'm at buzzfeed
and today we are going to read some
thirst tweets like nervous to hit the
thing see what you guys prepared for me
buzzfeed
can we talk about how stunning hayley
kiyoko is
that's a nice way to start my day thank
you my gay awakening was stella from
lemonade mouth i think it was also my
gay awakening as well
i wish i was crying on haley kyoko's
shoulder right now and she would tell me
something poetic and then make out with
me after and we'd get married
we're moving very quickly but i feel
like that's something that i would do
though would be like oh okay let's get
married it's a very lesbian thing to do
haley kyoko is the lesbian of my wet
dreams i'm the lesbian of your wet
dreams wow thank you so much i'm so
honored and concerned if anyone was
wondering my sexuality is taylor swift
and hayley kiyoko performing curious
together i love that tweet i feel like
that was a moment i'm so happy for your
sexuality congratulations my kink is
haley kyoko's dance solo and curious
that yeah
i feel like some of these are like how
do you respond to these you know it's
like awkward but also exciting that
you're somebody's kink you know i just
want to make out with haley kyoko in one
of her music videos where do i sign up
for that
thank you
i feel like uh emily and uh friends with
ross went and he's like i love you and
she's like thank you listen there have
been a lot of make-out situations in my
music videos and i'm grateful that you
love them
haley kyoko can i
lick in between your toes my toes just
like moved and my whole body just like
froze
you want to know something really weird
about me is growing up i would put
lubriderm this lotion in between my big
toe and my second toe because i started
to have anxiety if i couldn't move my
toes and my shoes if you were to lick
them between my toes they would be very
moisturized i'm just going to leave you
with that statement okay we're moving on
to the next one i'm not gay but i'd let
hayley kyoko choke me on the spot
i would be scared if i was choking you
that that is concerning i don't want to
choke you i love you i just want to hug
you and embrace you does anyone else
watch haley kyoko music videos and get
extremely wet i do have to say that most
of my music videos i feel like i'm
always submerging myself in a form of
water which
like sleepover i was in a bathtub
cliff's edge i was in a lake there's
always water involved interpret that how
you will but i'm also wet in the music
videos maybe i'm watching lemonade mouth
because haley kyoko is hot maybe
that was also in all caps by the way so
it was very indecisive but also like
very decisive because it was in all caps
that tweet remember that time and
insecure
when suddenly haley kyoko appeared out
of nowhere for a can i cuss on this
mother
what does mff mean mother
mff threesome with her titties out for
the camera an important moment in
television history i would say so as
well it was really funny too because i
just can't believe i did that
and yeah that is that is forever living
on our television screens i'm so glad
you enjoyed that i do have nice
must say to be honest my biggest sexual
fantasy is with hayley kyoko as velma
dinkley jinkies
so i have to say to that just saw hayley
kyoka's show in paris my nipples are
hard my brain is fuzzy my skin's on fire
and my voice is it was a religious
experience all hail lesbian jesus
i can't believe that's a real tweet i
feel very complimented and also very
concerned again they were going through
a lot at that show in paris they were
experiencing a lot of things haley kyoko
could undress me with a single look all
the way to my panties that's it that's
the thirst tweet it's a great thirst
tweet you're so welcome hayley kyoko the
only woman i will call daddy
i feel like i feel uncomfortable if i
would feel uncomfortable if someone
called me daddy haley kyoko could spit
in my mouth and choke me and i'd thank
her back to the choking people people
love the choking i would let hayley
kyoko shoot me with an arrow ngo what
does undeal mean not gonna lie
you can keep that in there
are you a top verse or bottom i'm
whatever haley kyoko needs me to be it's
very nice of you thank you so much for
your versatility i act like i'm okay but
deep down i want hayley kyoko to sit on
my face
i hope my parents aren't watching this
haley kyoko is so cute i want to eat it
from
they want to eat it from the back
that would be a no zone for me glad we
could clear that up it's getting hot in
here y'all so we're going to turn up the
ac haley kyoko can i please take you to
a beach read you poetry and then eat
your puppy as the sun sets
or
question mark what's after the question
mark
where do we go from there truly oh we're
really ramping up we're really ramping
up here i just want you to know that
below the camera my hand is like this
and like tense on my thigh okay i'm
putting it back down to its position
out for haley kyoko she owns my ass i
love her so much love you haley kyoko
could literally burn my house down and
steal everything i own and i'd still
want to eat her you need to start
thinking about your boundaries but i'm
also complimented thank you so much and
that's it that's all folks thank you all
so much for your incredible feedback and
the thirst tweets this was so much fun
make sure to check out my album panorama
which is out now i love you all so much
thanks buzzfeed
see ya
[Music]
you